I have a double mastectomy schedule for April 5th.
I've read your posts regarding tumor removal and fasting to
dial regulate MTOR and IGF post-surgery.
Should fasting start the day after surgery?
I would start the day of surgery.
So that's when I will start the day of surgery.
And to, you know, at least a 24-hour fast, maybe even a 48-hour
fast, but that's how you can tolerate it, that can help you heal
the best.
So, and then consider intermittent fasting or time restricted
eating after that, so that you're getting a fasting like
environment in your body so that you're not getting a
regulation of intermittent.
Should with which supplements should I continue to take
pre- and post-surgery, would you recommend cheek swabs,
pre- and post-surgery?
No, necessarily maybe a conversation with me would be good,
because then I could take a deeper dive into your supplements
that I've ever asked this question, and then I can give you
an analysis about that probably the best thing.
Would you recommend CBC or other lab test
pre- and post-surgery?
I would certainly think that they would do that.
I would certainly think that they would do that at the hospital
post-surgery.
You know, they would be hugely amiss without making sure
that your electrolytes aren't balanced before letting you
be dismissed from the hospital.
So, yes, getting a CBC with complete metabolic panel
and pre- and post-surgery would be both great.
The oncologist has suggested starting a new oral chemo
with an estrogen blocker of about two weeks post-surgery.
So, if you do make an appointment with we could discuss that
as well.